my question is that we all know sona has
a book coming out very soon we're very
excited about that oh thank you uh would
you ever consider writing a book i think
it'd be great yep i want to see how
sona's book goes first
wait why well because you know i don't
know i mean i've read through a lot of
sona's book but you know what if
i'm arrested after sona's book comes out
i would be arrested well yeah but you're
also you know the two of us should be
arrested together yes that's true
there's plenty of us just acting like
total idiots in the workplace so um yeah
but uh yeah i am interested in one day
writing i had a very unusual show
business life
and a lot of crazy twists and turns that
to this day are hard to explain to
people
um even kevin hart didn't quite know the
story of how i got the show back in 93
and i was talking to him the other day
and when i told him how i got the first
late night show his jaw fell off he just
couldn't understand that that was my
i've had a very improbable weird kooky
career i've been incredibly lucky uh and
um
had a lot of insane breaks and then
crazy crazy good things happen crazy bad
things happen and so i really do need to
uh
write it all down the one thing that
sometimes gets in the way is i don't
really want to like hurt people's
feelings and there's if i really told
the truth you know
there's some people that might not be
happy
um
but
i'll forgive you you'll get over it yeah
[Laughter]
but no i would very much like to do that
so um yeah but sona's book uh i have
read and it's really good it's really
funny and the crazy thing is that it's
all true so i'm looking forward to it
and conan wrote the forward i wrote a
forward to the
best part of the book no no no
i think people are going to like this
book because it's all
exactly true and you can't believe
that she wasn't fired 150 times
and you can't believe i wasn't fired 70
times so i'm really looking forward to
it and it's called world's worst
assistant yes it is yeah yeah comes out
in july
using your
thing to plug my book yeah well please
you can pre-order it now okay take it
easy all right that's now what you're
doing yeah
pre-order my book comes out july okay
that's fine yeah also
that's a lot of behind behind-the-scenes
stories yeah real fun anecdotes yeah
conan o'brien wrote the forward yeah
okay we get it yeah really great yeah
anything else you'd like to plug oh uh
sona's renting out her twins
[Laughter]
mikey and charlie are available for yard
work
they can't quite stand yet but you said
one of them can kind of crawl right one
of them is doing an army crawl yeah so
he can do some work right i
mean their dad is a former soviet so
we're getting them started pretty early
yeah
so yeah all right well my children this
is my babies and by my book pre-order
world the world's worst assistance
you're a just a terrible person